all right we
are now live for another reading
from my book uh reason fulfilled by
revelation
the 1930s christian philosophy debates
in france and today we are going to be
doing a kind of shorter reading and it's
on this
uh section historical development and
area
phases of the christian philosophy
debates
so not quite 10 pages
starts on page 39 finishes up on page
46 and next time we'll go into a
longer section and then after this we
will have
some q a and discussion about the book
the topics we won't be doing a lot of
general stuff this is not an ama
so this is a focused reading
specifically
on this work all right so with no
further ado
historical development and phases of the
christian philosophy debates
commentators on the debates have
occasionally distinguished stages or
phases of the debates articulating them
historically as well as thematically
more typically studies of the debates
have concentrated on main themes of the
interlocutors positions
and chronically rather than attending to
the diacronic development
and spread of the debates and the
interplay
between the positions the brief history
provided here
aims to assist further study of the
debates by filling in this gap
of perspective about the 1930s period it
also attempts to extend this history by
distinguishing additional phases of
scholarship on the debates
reappropriation and further development
of positions further new initiatives
in christian philosophy and the later
and smaller debates and discussions
about the issue
while acknowledging the inherent
artificiality of imposing clean dividing
lines on a field of intellectual
interactions as multifaceted as
intertangled as these debates such
division remains a useful device for the
sort of study in the history of ideas
provided in outline by this section
the debates begin 1931.
first phase of the debates runs from the
march 1931 meeting of the society
frances de philosophie
to blondel's reviewed metaphysique and
morale article near the end of the year
as pointed out earlier three main
positions on christian philosophy are
represented
in presentations and published work
during this early phase of the debate
the rationalist the zhilson maraten and
the blundellian ones
jill some brings up and criticizes
theologist phetest and neo-scholastic
positions against christian philosophy
but during this phase these positions
are not yet
actively championed during this portion
of the debates the main forums are the
closely associated
society frances de philosophie and the
review physique et de morale
while few notices of the discussion and
issues appear in other journals
and reggie jolie vet publishes two books
bearing on christian philosophy
these will draw little notice during the
debates
both of the rationalists take part in
the society francis de philosophy
session which was clearly set up by
xavier leon to be a primarily tag team
bout
between two rationalists and two tomists
bra here's provocative article is there
a christian philosophy and
braunschweig's first installments of
de la vre e
translated are published early on in the
year
joel song sets out and defends his
position at length during the society
frances de philosophy session
and then heads off to begin delivering
the first installation of his gifford
lectures
a first selection of which is published
that year in the journal
v ancelects you all mara 10 provides his
positions first systematic articulation
along
lines he will not change but merely
clarify
and add to in coming years blondel
engages both
rival positions in his two pieces
published that year
and begins developing his larger study
the problem of the philosophy catholique
blondel's work on that volume jill
sohn's own on the spirit of medieval
philosophy and mauritan's reworking of
his associate francis de
philosophy contribution into a lecture
given that lou
in december provide a bridge of
continuity between the first
and second phases the debates expand
1932-1933
the second phase of the debates begins
conveniently enough at the start of 1932
and ends just before the society thomas
meeting in september 1933.
during this phase several important
developments take place
foremost among these is the just
mentioned publications by jill saul
marita and blondel of three classic book
length works articulating
robust positions on christian philosophy
providing reference points for future
well-informed systematic study on the
subject
mara 10 further adds to his lecture
publishes it in the review
neo scholastic to the philosophy now
beginning to assume an important role
and then expands it into his book length
study essay on christian philosophy
blondel not only publishes his book but
discusses it with six other philosophers
in the november 1932 society detoured
for the sophie
session the rationalists drop out of the
discussion
making no further significant
contributions
and from this phase on the debates are
clearly between christian
mainly though not exclusively catholic
interlocutors
in compensation several new positions in
their own right those of marcel and
soriyo are added
a number of other interlocutors
including sertiyaj
born and sheneu make smaller
contributions to the debates
in a variety of journals and other
others publish pieces taking up one
major interlocutor's position or in
others
foreign interest in the topic of
christian philosophy and in the ongoing
french discussions begins
to manifest itself further development
of the debates
1933 to 1936.
the so the society thomas session
provides a convenient beginning point
for the third phase of the debates
since it signals the real entrance of
neo-scholastic opponents of christian
philosophy
fixing the other terminus at the end of
1935 is an admittedly somewhat more
arbitrary but
still defensible decision a number of
new developments at least an embryo are
concentrated in the report
of the 1933 society thomist session
the two main presenters forest and mot
articulate thomas positions for
christian philosophy
and argue the case for compatibility
between the joseon
and blondel positions in a lengthy
contribution
sertian begins to set out his own
position elaborating it in greater
detail later in this phase
a number of neo-scholastic set out
positions against christian philosophy
during the session
mass novo and mondonet getting into
argument with jill so on the matter
and foiling prefiguring noelle's later
article by using categories
of husserlian phenomenology to argue
against christian philosophy's rigor
well not speaking much during the
society to me session
the young von steinbergen would
afterward
articulate the strongest neo-scholastic
position
against christian philosophy
many other francophone philosophers and
theologians contribute interesting
pieces to the debates from many
uh different perspectives quite a few
thomas including bruno de sallage eve
simone andre mark pedro de [ __ ]
mtl penito and reginald garagou lagrange
take positions for or against christian
philosophy
a number of other thinkers most notably
henri goulier blaise romeyer and louis
paul couche
represent other currents of catholic
philosophy prefiguring a later set of
debates
three reformed protestant philosophers
and theologians
jacques bois pierre garrion and arnold
raymond
publish articles engaging the
controversy the
jewish philosopher leon first
installment of atenza jerusalem marks
the first and only intervention of a
phetheist into the debates proper
blondel joe so and mariten also continue
to develop
aspects of their positions further the
latter in science and wisdom
bloondell publishes the articles towards
an integral philosophy and office du
philos
philosoph while jillson delivers
lectures deliberately engaging
protestant conceptions of christian
philosophy published later in 1936
as christianity and philosophy
by 1936 however it becomes apparent the
francophone debates are drawing to a
close evidenced by examples such as the
title
made use the blonde and deba philosophy
reflection of philosophy and the
tendency of other articles for example
those by simone romeier and lubac
to summarize the debates lay out the
agreements attained
and suggest further topics
at the same time foreign interest in the
debates and discussion of christian
philosophy
continues study generating literature in
italian
spanish german english and latin
and contributions in five different
forums the
thomas society of ottawa discusses the
issue in 1933
and the dutch one in 1934 the eighth
international congress of philosophy in
the second international thomas congress
sees several presentations on the issue
and finally in 1936 the american
catholic philosophical association
includes several presentations on the
subject
after the 1930s debates a fallow period
1937-1946
after the debates proper one can still
distinguish a set of consecutive periods
in the last and current century
in which further developments bearing on
the issue of christian philosophy and to
a lesser extent the 1930s debates
continue to take place although in this
first
post-based post-debate phase there is a
marked decline of interest in the topic
of christian philosophy
kept by the dislocations other
preoccupations lack of communications
and shortages
during the years of world war ii
scholars continue to revisit the issues
julson and blondel in particular
published further works that while no
longer bearing as immediately
on christian philosophy nevertheless
develop their positions
further within the larger context of
their philosophical works
as wholes several articles and books on
christian philosophy
are published by other interlocutors and
alex renar publishes one of the first
book length studies on the debates
two theologians carl rauner and emil
bruner
briefly examine the debates and the
issue in their works
interestingly reflection on christian
philosophy by several francophone
reformed
protestant philosophers continues on
during this period
new debates and renewed perspectives
1947-1970
the post-world war ii years witnessed
renewed interest in the issue of
christian philosophy
spawning a sizable but increasingly
varied body of literature
until his death in 1949 and in several
posthumously published work published
works
blondel occasionally revisits the topic
as von steinberg and martin and jill
stone continue to do
through their long careers the four
bodies of work had come to be treated as
representative of now classic positions
on christian philosophy
and a genre of international secondary
literature
can begins to proliferate continuing on
to the present day
continuing of art consisting rather of
articles
dissertations and books more or less
successfully examining championing
critics criticizing
harmonizing or extending these positions
andrei ayang supplies an example of this
approach
providing exposition of blondel's early
philosophy
in one article arguing complementarity
of blondel's maritimes positions in
another
and discussing the status of anselms and
aquinas is thought as
christian philosophy in one particularly
interesting volume 18
philosophy several interlocutors in the
1930s debates contributed pieces
reflecting on jill sohn's contributions
to understanding christian philosophy
for a considerable portion of the new
literature on christian philosophy the
1930s debates and their main positions
continued to provide key starting points
vocabulary and concepts
and touchstones for further reflection
and study
although discussions on the scale of the
1930s debates
never again take place during this fifth
period several sustained discussions
about
christian philosophy do occur the
longest and largest of these are carried
out by reformed
protestant thinkers spurred particularly
by roger mel's
1940s study the condition of the
christian philosopher but
re-engaging the current of protestant
thinkers
and articles from earlier phases in this
case
we can legitimately speak of a 1940s to
1960s
francophone protestant christian
philosophy debate running in parallel to
but seemingly
little involved with the dutch and later
dutch american reform tradition
of christian philosophy in addition to
those mentioned earlier edmond roshdew
paul recur and pierre tevinas become
involved in these discussions
another set of much more loosely
connected discussions occasionally
takes place in american circles
involving among others dietrich von
hildenbrand
and jermaine grizz as a last note the
philosopher and biblical scholar
claude premontant develops at great
length and considerable detail an
interesting new catholic position on
christian philosophy
particularly in his etude physique
biblic
christian philosophy in times of
pluralism and postmodernism 1971 to the
present
it also makes sense to speak of a sixth
even yet wider and still ongoing phase
consisting in reappropriation
and reinterpretation of the debate and
its issues
in a newly realized late modern
situation of philosophical pluralism
in the present day in this sixth phase
the possibility
and the nature of christian philosophy
still remains an open
complex and alluring question nearly
every position
developed in the course of the debates
finds its present-day proponents
and some possess quite erudite
expositors
there are of course some new
philosophical developments new ways of
approaching the issues but
much of the possible discussions or
investigations
of christian philosophy's possibility or
nature particularly
those carried out by authors unfamiliar
with the 1930s debates
inevitably remains within the shadows
cast
by the earlier and more monumental
stages
in recent years more closely
philosophical of closely focused
philosophical attention
has been devoted to certain basic issues
phenomena
and conditions that were often
overlooked by previous generations
of philosophers and that are of interest
and relevance to christian philosophy
just as much
as to philosophy in general adrian
pepperzak for example recently wrote
i am aware that these questions have
been debated before particularly in
france 60 years ago but the situation
has changed
profoundly since the heyday of neotomism
neoscholasticism has disappeared
exegesis
and history have shown how many meanings
the word christian has
the modern idea of an autonomous
philosophy has made
room for conceptions according to which
philosophy is always rooted
in pre-philosophical soil and fed by
non-philosophical
moods mauries and traditions while his
contention that neo-scholasticism has
vanished as contestable the other
developments he signals set contemporary
reflection
on christian philosophy in novel
conditions
christian philosophy faces new
intellectual and cultural opponents
challenges and temptations possible
interlocutors
and tasks fortunately it also possesses
a treasury of considerable
considerable resources and a stable of
erudite champions
including in recent years pope's john
paul ii and benedict the 16th
to conclude these speculations about
this last phase extending into the
millennium
i wish to stress that labeling it as a
sixth phase
of the christian philosophy debates
indicates a commitment to interpreting
the considerable body
of contemporary literature on christian
philosophy as making points of contact
with the debates positions interlocutors
and interpreters
within intellectual and historical
frameworks generated by the 1931-1936
phases of the christian philosophy
debates these
earlier stages however as i hope these
introductions have shown
and as i am confident the translations
following will display
we're not a closed intellectual arena
that can be set aside as a finished
historical product
for three important reasons each of
which also applies to the present stage
first some of the issues and the
controversies brought to light are so
basic so fundamental so inherent in and
relevant to any contemporary philosophy
that aims at adequate self-reflection
that they possess a certain sort of
inexhaustible perenniality second
approaches to these matters had their
roots in stimulation in a wider and yet
living past context
of christian life and culture one that
like all living past carried itself
forward
into the present of the 1930s and still
continues on into our new millennium
third as the best of the debates
literature indicates the reflexive
projects of christian philosophy
must not only appropriate reinterpret
and thereby continue past intellectual
traditions
and not only so deepen their analyses to
strive for both perennial philosophical
achievements
and to enter into the mysteries upon
which these rest they must also in their
philosophical work
enter into dialogue with the wide range
of interlocutors even those
bitterly hostile and perversely
unwilling that providence has set in
their path
these are precisely what the debate's
best interlocutors did
in the 1930s they thus provide us with
time-tested models
and intellectual frameworks for us
present-day christian philosophers
to take up these tasks in our turn
so that's the end of that section the
next section that we'll be going into
for the reading it continues on with the
historical introduction but it's the
thematic introduction
outlines of positions articulated during
the debates and we'll begin with that
um in the next session so let me see
what we've got up here
uh the monarch wants to thank me for the
content i've put out i'm glad
to read that fabian asks are you part of
any other clubs that need to discuss
philosophy
uh yes but you know that's that's a
research project for you to carry out
online you can go to my social media
about the ones that i participate in
elijah i've been reading books on
blondel lately i'd be
glad grateful to hear of your ideas of
radical differences between blondel's
account of
action and hegel's essential differences
similarities
um hegel doesn't have an account of
action there's one part
essential difference right there hegel
discusses action at many points but he
doesn't have an account
of action uh by the way the probably the
most interesting
parts of his discussions i would say
that aren't in the philosophy of right
take place in the phenomenology in the
morality section
of uh spirit blondel devotes a
very different kind of phenomenological
and systematic attention that is
dialectical but not dialectical
necessarily in hagel's way
don't let um the being called the french
hegel
or the catholic hegel mis mislead you
into thinking that they're
basically on the same level when it
comes to these sort of things
um retro gamer knowing nothing of the
content of the debates or issues is a
very dry history i look forward to the
translation
get the book
don't complain right um if
the book is easy enough to get your
hands on and the translations are
contained in the book not just
translation but translations
if you find it dry maybe this isn't
something to join in on um you know
maybe it's better just to read it
all right uh post-structuralist
scholastic seems to mean something other
than catholic school of
of theology there's no catholic school
of theology or catholic schools
and movements of theology there has
never
ever been throughout the entire history
of the church one single
catholic school of theology
scholastic or neo-scholastic are
referring to
taking things from the scholastic period
so
abelard and anselm on forward all the
way to people like
you know through thomas and and and um
uh albert all the way through to don
scotus and um akam and
and actually beyond you know john
poinsau and people like that suarez
um so in the one thing in the attorney
potress
this is this really important encyclical
document
that that pope leo the 13th brought out
it was urged that there should be a
return to scholastic philosophy and that
there should be institutional
support for that right and so part of
that institutional support consisted
in new uh academic institutions
like um leuven and so and and also like
you know the review nail scholastic
right so
new journals that would focus on
reinterpreting
not just thomas aquinas but also all all
these other
uh scholastic authors anselm isn't
really a scholastic he's still a
monastic writer and he's kind of suey
generous
abelard is clearly you know somebody who
falls within that that scope and then
there's many other
writers as well some of whom are better
known now like you know for example
henri of ghent
um who i know people who do work on but
wasn't being read that much at that time
so there's this incredible
effort being put in at certain places
in reviving
not just thomistic but other scholastic
thought
and it was done largely by catholics the
the interesting thing is now
um aquinas is probably being read by
just as many protestants as he is by
catholics because many of them have
recognized they shouldn't have thrown
that baby out with the bathwater
of dismissing catholic thought and
thomas were
all over the map um when it came to
these christian philosophy debates many
of them were very influenced
by maurice blondel antonin sertian bruno
de salaj
you know some some classic examples of
that henry the lubach
thomism was kind of a lingua franca that
you were stuck with
at the time um
so that's probably enough about about
scholasticism
um ricky i wrote exegesis paper once and
never again i have no idea what that
means
tyler sass crushing i love my work well
that's great so uh
questions about what we're talking about
here
the book the work that went into it the
landscape
intellectual of the time um what have we
got because
um that's what we're focused on here
this is not a general ama
this is me taking time out of my
day to to do a live reading and then
talk with all of you about some of the
uh discussions um
general questions on kojevan is reading
of hegel save that for
for an ama um any
if we don't have any other questions or
comments
or discussion specifically about that
i'll just give you a preview
of of what is to come um there's another
about you know 50 pages or so
of introduction the next sections are
going to be the rationalists which are
emil brellier
and leon brunswig revelation generative
of reason a section on etienne josou
philosophy in a christian state jacques
mariten catholic philosophy maurice
blondell
the paradox and the scandal gabrielle
marcel
neo-scholastic tomist opponents of
christian philosophy
thomas proponents of christian
philosophy and
non-thomas proponents of christian
philosophy and that takes us up to page
91 and then once we're through those
which will probably take you know a few
sessions
i'm going to start reading some of the
uh 12 different chapters of translated
material from this starting with emil
brellier finishing up with
leon noel and you know
it might be helpful for people to
actually get the book
uh and read ahead if you don't want to
then then you
get to hear me reading through it um
thomas says just tuned in is there
anything you learn took away from your
work you didn't realize before going
into it
yeah i mean this was this was a project
that took me
from about 2003
to 2011 and the research
that was done on it took place
roughly between 2003 to 2008
continued a little bit more after that
much of the research was done
at the notre dame hesburgh library
talked about that a little bit in some
of the earlier sessions
and um
yeah i mean i i started out not knowing
that the debate
included about 50 different people
uh including about you know we could say
ten major positions on the debates
um and that you know i had i i didn't
even suspect the existence of many of
the documents that i later
decided to include for a translation in
here
this was like in
francophone circles this was like one of
the
key philosophical topics of discussion
for a good
five years um and probably would have
continued on
longer had world war ii not intervened
um so you know i i
well you know i i've actually got a
video on this so i don't need to go into
this too much the one that i
remastered recently and released about
national library week and the whole
project
how i ended up doing the the research so
a lot a lot of that was
surprise after surprise after surprise
pleasant surprises
post structuralist are you getting back
to rickur
i never left raquer but i'm not getting
back to him in the sense of like doing
more work on recore
um he's just an ever presence person on
my shelf who i take down every once in a
while
uh tyler says aquinas seems to fall in
alignment with aristotle would this make
aristotle a proto-christian no it would
not
um any more than it would make cicero a
proto-christian
i don't know why why we'd want that to
even be the case
um and aristotle doesn't have an
emphasis on logos and its essential
divinity
you have in mind instead the
neoplatonists and the stoics
on that matter not aristotle
aquinas is actually out of alignment
with aristotle on many topics
where he says that aristotle got things
wrong um
one thing would be on the eternity of
the world
all right any any questions about the
the book the topics otherwise i'm going
to bring this one to
a little bit of an early close and we'll
have
longer reading next time
which will be happening this coming
weekend
um ricky says how did the debate impact
the critical explanation and
interpretation of christian text i don't
know what you
exactly have in mind with that um it
didn't it was about christian philosophy
not primarily about christian texts so
all right let's wrap it up um thanks for
everybody for
showing up for this one and uh like i
said we'll have
plenty more coming up down the line
there are many more
readings if we do about 10 to 15 pages
at a time i think this will certainly
take me the rest of the summer and maybe
even
into fall so have a great day wherever
you are
and i'll see you at the next one